Master Wayne well imaging is showing me  two dozen hostiles on the third floor  whenever I drop you off on the second  I'm getting slow in my old age effort  even you got to hold die young not for  lack of trying he has the power to wipe  out the entire human race if we believe  there's even a one-percent chance that  he is our enemy we have to take it as an  absolute greatest gladiator match in the  history of the world God vs Man  day versus night you're psychotic it was  a three-syllable word for any thought  too big for little minds  but now if you wouldn't like you I don't  think you've ever known a woman like me  you know the oldest line in America  the power can be innocent  you  you